[Musique]
voilà une opération qui s'inscrit dans
une longue durée puisque il y a déjà
plusieurs dizaines d'années
que les pouvoirs publics on ont
transféré ou créé ici de grandes
institutions
académiques universitaires ou
scientifique comme le CA l'Université de
Paris Sud et puis plus récemment l'École
polytechnique supelc à chausé et cetera
et de grands établissements de recherche
alors évidemment le démarrage de ce
projet a rencontré d'autres visions
celle des agriculteurs qui sont présents
sur le plateau celle des des
associations qui qui protège désireuse
de protéger l'environnement et le
patrimoine qui est très important ici et
celle aussi de tous ceux qui
s'inquiètent euh de ce que pourrait être
les problèmes de transport de toute
cette
population universitaire en particulier
qui viendrait ici donc les pouvoirs
publics que ce soit l'État les
collectivités locales aussi qui sont
très présentes dans ce projet évidemment
sont confronté à la ce qu'on appelle la
société civile et la concertation et
bien cela consiste à faire se rencontrer
à travers des procédures qui sont prévu
par la loi ou qui sont créé de toute
pièces ici la ce qu'on appelle la
société civile et pouvoir public de
façon à ce qu'il
dialogue la concertation a porté dès le
début de 2011 2012 sur la
délimitation de cette de cette zone
agricole
protégée elle a été assez étroite et
elle abouti à la sortie d'un texte un
décret qui protège donc ici un vaste
ensemble de terres agricoles de forêts
et de zones
naturelles le dialogue est actif il
reste des désaccords
importants il y a toujours une fraction
de la société civile qui qui regrette
l'ampleur prise par cette opération
d'autres considèrent que c'est parti et
qu'il faut l'accompagner avec des moyens
de transport une protection de
l'environnement solide voilà les termes
du débat
aujourd'hui